welcome to this video stop sness su
darkness from iceland maybe I can do
something else not the Queen's Gambit
all of the time trying to get something
doing with the London system yeah here
in fact White has some chances to play
for an advantage that's it's quite quite
nice for white actually okay I'm going
to try to preserve the bishop and then
play before b5m j9 f 3 a 92 b3f is the
plan
like I really should try to get Bishop
e7 d8 in is not doing that and this
might cost him when I get to a 5 it's
really really difficult for black to
defend the b7 pawn I don't really see
how he does it actually maybe he has to
do something drastic with e5 already
yeah Knight a5 is a huge drat
yeah kind of necessary right yeah if I
take it here's 94 which is well
certainly nothing I care fear very much
however Knight a5 is is really nice I
mean yeah why not
I'm just getting the d7 pawn a b7 pawn
and when I get to b7 with the night I
mean the knight on d6 is not exactly
badly placed it also comes with a big
fork on King Bishop and rook so what
it's not clear to me what is what is
playing now I'm going to take yeah I
know I can just take on b7 I think Ruby
8 yeah I mean I just play okay I will
take it I mean let's let's just take it
first and then check think about it
right this rook why not the other look
John I cannot tell you
so let's see I can now grab various I
cannot win material in various ways what
is the best way maybe take this first
he's got Bishop d3 and oh that wasn't
very precise really
I was I wasn't I wasn't really thinking
about it here in like 96 he has Bishop
III and this I can take he a droopy aid
I'm still losing he - hmm
this was really unnecessary I really
should have thought about it for more
than kill him yeah because this is what
he deserves after the opening okay let's
let's continue here it's still probably
not that bad I have Bishop d6 as a
threat amongst others but it's still of
course totally unnecessary to get the
position it should have been over
already and I could have just taken me
five okay
oh wow
yeah this really didn't work out too
well before was hanging him maybe I have
to do that
please does equal material I don't have
lost any any material and maybe 96 Jeff
five of our managed it's a little bit
surprised that he went here and not
somewhere on every year like where he
might where the bishop can do something
useful here it is protecting this is six
pawn but I'm not sure how relevant that
really is yeah I know I get let me think
about it I have to do that get to take
f7m and age six
nice deep horn might be might be a
victim okay so he's playing a somewhat
passive move maybe look f6 is idea
possible
okay I have to move this anyway I guess
and how to do this I wonder
ruk f6 still possible I have rope gases
check though makes it difficult for me
to make headway
check check again I also have b3
this chick didn't didn't really help
right
maybe this intending to be three I need
to get something active going get a d6
pawn
hmm tricky check
hmm the depot as mentioned earlier is
it's not easy not easy to fight yeah
some Brooksie - maybe d3 even d3 94 yeah
I may be holding he's taking lots ground
Arthur I know I don't really see a
reason to - Jack check the draw I mean I
really don't understand what's going on
maybe I'm not in such a bad shape here
okay check check check check
cry I can draw a graph oh yeah I'm
really lost Here I am
and winning this on time feels terrible
I mean I'm really an idiot yeah this
position is like just winning for white
and I didn't why am I not winning here
it's just just bad play the easiest is
to just take this really I mean it's not
that I didn't see it but I thought the
other one is just clearer something like
that is just it's just a win yeah
nothing nothing more nothing less I keep
this pawn I get to default he's toast
but somehow this wasn't why isn't this
like totally winning because I'm an
idiot right I have to play every year of
course yeah no you just have to look at
it his only counter play is 94 yeah and
if I just play this this is stopped
simply stopped and I will take here and
just win yeah that's really easier
that's really easy
and here i'm i don't know i mean it's
it's probably still open you have to
play 92 we're 92 but this is always this
is almost this is almost play for black
and this is getting yeah I should
computer just test shoes just wants to
cancel short and says I'm winning yeah
still a good yeah it's still good
because of this yeah my main problem was
that I mean I also didn't see this idea
which isn't even any good yeah rupees
seven takes and just keep the one
instead of taking this yeah this is in
fact I mean I really play badly here
right
this is justice this is also very good
for what much better much better than
the than the game as this is now really
weak yeah if he tries to cover it I can
I can win over that here the c6 pawn oh
it was really a terrible game and then I
even can't even blunder this is piece
and check a channel here is deep one is
very strong but I gave up I thought he
was just giving up the corner I'd really
didn't see that check yet he I'm winning
one time but I mean after playing this
is so total nonsense I really didn't
want to run out of time wow what a bad
game yeah no came thanks for watching